first let's screw so much stuff let's do
this first a Canadian parliamentarian is
apologizing after a standing ovation was
given to a 98 year old veteran allegedly
belonging to a not allegedly hold on he
was he fought with the Nazis not just
the Nazis the Waffen SS this guy was was
a super Nazi if you know a super Nazi
I have been laughing at this so hard
allegedly look Marsh here's the thing
what do you mean I've been laughing at
this so hard for like a year or two now
because we've literally been fighting
with Nazis that I know a guy who killed
himself because he supported them two
years ago so yeah this has been
hilarious now look I know that but the
part that's funny is that now we're
parading them out and pitting medals on
their chests and [__] we are let me tell
you something to you Marsh
it's not that we know all that stuff's
been happening but you all it would take
was like how did because when when they
give these these commendations or
whatever it doesn't it in any country in
any civilized country it passes through
a couple desks right a couple people
have to see it and not what he said
hey real quick nobody has Google no just
real quick this guy fought in World War
II against the Russians just that
sentence right you would go wait a
second you go which side let me just
double check real quick hold on against
the Russians and notice something they
didn't even call them the Soviet Union
they called them the Russians the
Russians yeah we're back to the 80s
nation was given to 98 year old veteran
allegedly belonging to a Nazi
in World War II
blunder took place during Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski Ukrainian
did she say Ukrainian I was saying boo
cranian Ukrainian
country and the dress to Canada's House
of Commons veteran yaroslav hunger quote
stood and appeared to salute when he was
recognized by houses what did the salute
look like I'm just curious I'm curious
you know it just makes you think of the
Roman Empire again it's really [__]
funny
this is it but now all I can think about
is remember when Dennis and Dee like
found that video of their Grace
and that's why we gotta stop all these
ends in shades
nirota who introduced Hanka as a
Canadian Ukrainian war hero well I mean
okay we left look that's Lying by
Omission he he is Ukrainian and he
fought in a war and depending on who he
asked he is a hero so they didn't lie
they just let they just omitted some
details our hero
we have here in the chamber today
Ukrainian oh my God they make you dress
like that bro
hey you know a woman's a joke this
government is a joke hey virgin hey
virgin virtue we got any quick roasts
back there I'm [__] I'm starving I
was literally gonna say they dress you
like the Quaker Oats that's exactly what
he looks like you got that Mayflower
drip
yo what's up dog yo you come here on the
Nina the pinto the Santa Maria yo this
guy's all about Manifest Destiny Dog by
the way my aunt and queens used to have
that chair
oh [__] my lesbian aunt my lesbian aunt
in Long Island used to have that shirt
yeah but my heterosexual aunt had that
chair in Queens but she had plastic on
it and no one's allowed to sit on it
here in the chamber today Ukrainian
Canadians Ukrainian Canadian World
veteran
from the second world war look at him
through the math look at him through the
math [__] the Ukrainian Independence
against the Russians uh uh oh wait
slowly Dawning on him
oh no that was a deep breath yeah I want
you like wait a minute against the
Russians and he's not he's not British
French or American okay look I want you
to look I want you to look at his
eyebrows okay because his eyebrows is
the most telling thing I want this is
like this is like the meme or the person
standing in front of all the graphs to
charge yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay why
don't you look at his eyebrows
fought the Ukrainian Independence
against the Russians
uh oh boy wait a minute we're narrowing
this down all right hey what which one
of those two countries did the Canadians
fight with him
he fought the Russians in World War II
and his name's not Steve Rogers no he's
no he's not no he was not frozen
like this is something and he's not
named Bucky Barnes this isn't good
and continues to support the troops
today
okay look at the face which troops look
at the face
um dude honestly does this just feel
like Fred Willard's doing this this
seems like a joke I told you that's why
I've been laughing so hard this feels
like a [__] joke
oh Royce it is it doesn't feel like it
is this is all a [__] joke now the
are these people nobody not one person
not one person thought you know what
let me fact let me just go ahead and
just be the guy that goes hey real quick
you understand look I'll do Hey look I'm
a middle man I'll do you I'll do what
you tell me but are you sure you want to
give a medal to a Nazi is that what
you're sure about that this is this is
also the path of most resistance yeah
like siding with Ukraine
it's so unnatural like we could be
siding with a majority white Christian
Nation with its own identity who
historically speaking outside of like
the Cold War years we've always
historically gotten along with and we
could just agree to stay out of each
other's way and and both Prosper but
instead we are going with the human
trafficking bio lab money laundering
capital of the world like who who's
literally run by Jewish Nazis
which honestly is a thing now that's a
thing that there is now it's like it's
like we want to make the world as funny
as possible it is very funny right now
though you have to admit this is some of
the funniest stuff going on end game
stuff like when they told us about the
tribunal that was always really scary
and it is but they never told you it was
going to be this hilarious right no you
would have never thought it would be
this kind of funny you know
world war three is just gonna be you
know what I the only way that'll make
this better is if like when the nukes go
off they also have like a bunch of
confetti and like party streamer
materials in them
uh let's see here that maybe make a
clown horn noise when they detonate
uh the uh DeLeo guy says uh Dolphins
play a real team next week you mean the
bills that lost to the Jets
yeah we'll be all right
yeah honestly the bills ain't been you
know we'll be all right raining down hot
fire either lately like and I've I've
lost money betting on the bills this
year because like it's the bills I
thought it was Josh Allen I thought this
was a no-brainer
this age of 98. hear me out guys I can
make this this war funnier
we we take all the speakers off of ice
cream trucks and we start putting them
on our Abrams tanks and just play the
Entertainer over them
[Music]
I don't hate this idea
honestly we don't even need to do all
that hey Virgie just go put the
Entertainer and dub that over footage of
like them dropping bombs on injured
soldiers cut be right back Chief dude
did you see that you saw the war crime I
can't react to any of it on Twitter
because I'm I'm a we're a cat Channel
now but um I've been seeing it
holy [__] we're just we're just
committing war crimes and then posting
them on Twitter and we're like LOL
oh [__] and then and then people saying
oh technically people defending it
technically it can't be a war crime
because you you can't uh you you can't
surrender to a drone
and it's like well that's a weird
workaround to do a war crime
I remember I remember like
being pretty bloodthirsty after 9 11
right yeah but I don't remember being as
bloodthirsty as these pro-ukrainian
people like I still remember even at the
height of the war on terror whenever it
would come out that we committed some
kind of War crime I'd go hey we uh
probably shouldn't be doing that right I
hate these people too but Jesus Christ
maybe not like you know maybe not
bombing weddings and [__] like yeah
maybe we should dial it back but did you
create Pro Ukrainian people were like
yeah get them get that piece of [__] and
you're like they Just Dropped a Bomb on
a guy that's leg was already blown off
like that who was a war crime he was
supposed to treat the wounded actively
surrendering yes it's actively waving a
white flag and you're just like ah we'll
drop a bomb on them
hell yeah brother hell yeah brother
HH brother you deserve it
no it's Ukrainian Wars would be fight
forever
fight forever
laughs
yeah it's quite an ovation
man these guys really love Nazis you
guys really love that Nazi waffing as
this guy
meanwhile if we jokingly clap for a guy
like that we would lose our entire
Channel holy [__]
beautiful this is a beautiful thing that
happened
I like this only because for one reason
and that's like okay you know and I've
said this on Highway before you know
there were times in the past when you
know you would doubt whether or not you
were on the right side of History you
know we all have self-doubt sometimes
you're like you know I don't trust the
government but wait maybe I'm the bad
guy who knows yeah the the powers that
be have never made it more clear for you
that you're on the right side of History
right like like the the deliberate
decisions they've made up to this point
there's no longer any kind of doubt in
my mind that I'm on the right side of
History like you're literally now doing
four minutes standing O's for [__]
waffing as that's officers I think I can
get off this boat this shit's funnier
than anything Hollywood has written in
15 years just this but naturally the
thing that's happening it hasn't been
this funny since Tropic Thunder no uh
amen I [__] Amen to that it has none
this this new world is hilarious and if
you you guys can't find look do we get
mad sometimes we get sad sometimes we
get upset it's fine but if you cannot at
least find your way to laugh through
some of this stuff I don't know what to
tell you this is hilarious look how long
the supplies goes for
foreign
[Laughter]
it's like he's accepting a Hall of Fame
trophy
you know what
I came to Ukraine with two bad knees
and a dream
killing Jews
it keeps you
oh [__]
this is you shouldn't be a flossing this
long though right yeah no no he killed a
lot of Jews
it was a lot of Jews it was a lot of
Jews
his name is
he's a Ukrainian hero okay
and we thank him for all his service
thank you thank you thank you for your
service as you can see in the clip wrote
his words received a lengthy Applause
and lots of waving from the floor
including from zelinski and Canadian
Prime Minister Minister Justin Trudeau I
like whatever lives a tick tock share
something because then I know exactly
how soon Ian miles Chong's about to
steal something like that's how you
could tell no that's how you tell that's
how you could tell
feel it happening Malaysian [__]
yesterday Malaysian [__] get a dog
killer a game Elation dog killing [__]
him to the honoring of Hunka saying but
you know the worst part is the hypocrisy
had been a member of the Waffen SS unit
which was comprised of ukrainians
according to the Washington Post it's
just like of all things he could have
been
like it's not like like because they
tried this remember they tried this with
Trump and like anybody affiliated with
Republicans they're always like always
great grandfather uh invested in a tire
company or or they was connected to the
Nazis in the 30s and you're like all
right that's a stretch or they did it
with the other Pope they did it with the
other Pope who was forced to be in
Hitler Youth like he didn't have a
choice right oh yeah and they grew up in
Bavaria yeah yeah yeah remember that
remember that one that was a fun one for
everybody he was like eight yeah yeah
yeah no and then with this though it's
like the guy was literally like an
officer in the Waffen SS let's go ladies
and gentlemen bro they didn't look at
his early life on Wikipedia real quick I
mean they didn't see that like again
just like that other guy that was
reading the thing even it was Dawning on
him as he fought in the height of the
World War II against the Russians oh God
that's not an American name uh that's
not a British guy
that's not a french guy either this is
gonna get this is oh it's Slavic this is
gonna get hairy oh anytime anytime a
slob tells you he fought against the
Russian no no no no but rinko's got to
tell you a volunteer fighter in the
Waffen SS which is which is an extra
step version because you had to go yeah
I'll do it
what I'll do it what I'm saying yeah not
only volunteer but I'm just saying
anyone who fought the Russians east of
Germany let's say fair enough fair
enough I hear you it's it's probably
like once you get into those Slavic
regions and you're like oh you fought
the Russians hey with not a lot of
American Support
um were you what happened this was the
only other option this is this is this
is so God it's so good this is so good
post Heinrich Himmler who was a leading
member of the night I'm sorry I got to
hear that again because I don't know
we're gonna drop some Himmler stuff
member of the Waffen SS unit which was
comprised of ukrainians according to the
Washington Post Heinrich Himmler who was
a leading member of the Nazi party of
Germany formed the Waffen SS the group
was involved with mass shootings
anti-partisan Warfare yes shootings were
they [__] in cells yeah they were
they were Supreme gentlemen
and guards for Nazi concentration camps
where it never changes merch but it's
like they're even trying to work in to
take our guns thing when they're talking
in the context of a war mass shootings
yeah that's a war stupid [__] answer
no point Warfare and support that didn't
involve mass shootings
yeah that's literally what a war is it's
one big man shoot now you have me
thinking of the Roman Empire again
no
I'm sad
partisan Warfare and supplying guards
for Nazi concentration camps
okay
wow there were the Restaurant Depot of
contact concentration camp cards
as far as like as far as all these
people are concerned he should be like a
hyper Nazi dude he would yes you're
right he's a Nazi that got all seven
Chaos Emeralds yeah
where's cue the Sonic Adventures theme
I'm telling you the first level [__] it
[Music]
that explains how they killed so many
people and and got rid of them in such a
short amount of time oh [__] Chaos
Emeralds oh my God we solved the [__]
police officer yeah that's how they
cremated six million bodies so fast
foreign
speaking of the Holocaust just Ukrainian
award has called a cost us too much
it turned out it Holocaust us everything
yeah it really did it really really did
start writing schizophren theories about
how the first uh Sonic game is an
allegory for World War II hey real quick
and this is something that I just
thought of and I don't know why I didn't
think about this earlier
some mentioned the idiot on the chat to
reminding me
um has the ADL come out and contempt
this yet
I can assure you based on just me
following people on Twitter a lot of
folks have been tagging Jonathan
greenplat in the ADL why isn't he
condemning this
what happened to Jonathan greenblatt
oh probably because they want a greater
Israel
yeah remember when greater Israel was
like you know supposed to be just like
an extended part of Israel and now it's
concludes Ukraine mm-hmm
I thought greater Israel was Boca
day for what occurred on Friday that's
actually lesser Israel oh okay okay
is more
hi Les Grossman here I'll be uh I'll be
taking care of you today
I don't think I've ever I think I've
only
I never used to go to Boca except that I
had one Jewish weed dealer for a while
yeah
I really I really want business cards
that say less gross spent sometimes less
is more yeah I love that
I used to have a Jewish uh weed dealer
in Boca and he was this guy that was
I've told Royce about this guy before he
always had to show you his cool stuff oh
God I got here it was literally always
20 minutes of him showing you his cool
stuff for you did he have cool stuff
though I hated him
like it was all [__] that like it was
like yeah check this out bro surround
sound I had to put in check it out I get
it he had an apartment with an elevator
but it was like on the second floor and
the elevator only took like four so like
it was faster to take the stairs and be
insisted on taking the elevator every
time I hated this guy yo check it out
this Vizio 1080p it's pretty cool right
but by the way if you own a condo with
an elevator that goes right into your
condo which is kind of cool but it's on
the second floor it's not that
impressive it's not oh my God you're
right it's not everybody taking the
elevator for the experience of like huh
pretty cool huh it's like we could have
gotten in here soon you go on the
balcony and you go I could make this
jump and not even break my leg I can
make this jump and not break not even
sprain my ankle yeah
in the gallery I have subsequently
become aware of more information which
causes well I think I believe that
Trudeau has said something let me look
now you're gonna love this here you go
this is Trudeau I'm gonna assume let me
let me assume before you play this I'm
gonna assume that Trudeau just I don't
know had like a hundred working class
Canadians rounded up
okay remember when he was calling people
who didn't want to take the vacs Nazis
yeah remember when the Canadian
government decided that Hong Kong was
the euphemism for Heil Hitler yeah that
was really funny remember that
and then and then they invited who often
asked remember and literally and
literally said hail Hitler on the
parliament floor
foreign
oh [__] you still can't have GoFundMe
Jesus [__] Christ dude
uh
obviously it's extremely upsetting that
this happened uh the speeder speaker has
uh acknowledged his mistake and is
apologized but this is something that is
deeply embarrassing to the parliament of
Canada and by extension to all Canadians
no no
no no no you're just gonna move no
actually no not all Canadians see
because they don't they don't have a see
we've learned watching your government
in the last five years that they don't
get a say in [__] anything they don't
that's like saying this Ukraine war is
an embarrassment for All American
citizens most of us don't want to be
there
that's a good point we're like guys we
don't look we don't want this either you
know you want to go like look guys we're
not we don't want this yeah you guys
constantly [__] up and then constantly
every time you [__] up you go hey look
we've all made mistakes okay we're all
embarrassed here like
I'm not the one who got drunk and took a
[__] in the fish tank in front of
everybody at the Christmas party that's
on you don't say hey you know what on
behalf of all of us I'm very embarrassed
like yeah I didn't do anything I behaved
the whole time
those were angelfish they cost this guy
a lot of money
they ate the poop
they ate the poop and died what are you
eating
I think particularly of Jewish MPS and
all members of the Jewish Community
across the country who are celebrating
young or commemorating Yom Kippur today
that's right guys all our Jewish members
of parliament which make up 30 of our
Parliament despite only being two
percent of our population but don't
start thinking about that I think it's
going to be really important that all of
us push back against Russian propaganda
Russian disinformation and continue
ourselves
what does this have to do with the
Russian propaganda or this information
you did this this no there was not a
this was not a disinformation campaign
if yeah if anybody was misinformed it
was you sir
what did you send me a Virgie oh I I did
the thing it said check your deals okay
it took me a second but I did the thing
no
[Music]
by the way I like that he did an 8-bit
version yeah because now it feels like
it's playing I'm playing a video game
right doesn't it just feel like you're
playing an old shitty game
I made that on the Fly
[Music]
somebody somebody in the chat said
Trudeau they're not gonna hate Nazis now
you had a standing ovation
[Music]
you know what I like about this 8-bit
version too is that they didn't they
didn't make this to the right like right
so it's slow I literally made it I made
it okay it's it's slower and sadder than
the original first I do which actually
makes it funnier I love it I love that
you just titled it entertain
hey are you not entertained
thank you for noticing merch
it is funnier when it's just like
like we're all clown pilled but going
through the motion sadly that's exactly
what this is that's
exactly what that that's great
you know what I think I think I've
chosen the song I'm Gonna because now
that I'm learning my wise stuff and like
it's I'm even hooking speeches do you
want it I can send you the wave right
now yeah I want it just now I know well
no because I'm gonna use the original
because I don't have to worry about
copyright I'm gonna this is gonna be the
song that plays now when somebody's
trapped in my home and I'm hunting them
so you remember that chick that you just
mentioned that said the that that Hong
Kong commit Heil Hitler yeah want to see
what she has to say about this
oh was this her okay yeah
I want to
please ask all colleagues
particularly those in the Conservative
Party of Canada
to make sure that we do not politicize
this issue
of what I'm sorry oh wait the Nazi guys
that's what she specifically does she's
talking about the Nazi guy that's
specific let's not make what I did a
thing okay let's not make a whole thing
out of the fact that we gave a one
minute and Hoot and Holler and standing
ovation Nazi
a ma'am may I ask that uh if let's say a
member of the conservative party
had um made a misstep like this and
brought a literal ex-member full office
that's in and they had us standing o may
I ask would you extend the same courtesy
of not politicizing this
you don't think you imaginative Trump
had an ex-wop and S that Sky when he was
president oh my God that'd be a great
war hero folks fought for his country we
love people of fight for the country
him
oh [__]
why is this issue I don't think it helps
anybody
I think we need to make sure that we
move forward
recognize yeah you sound like every
woman who's ever cheated like in a
relationship right look okay we made
mistakes but I think we need to move on
and not dwell on it it's like you did
this last night that was you you know
what I mean you just did this your mate
your lipstick gets still smeared and
you're already talking about hey let's
not dwell on the past
and stand in solidarity together to
reiterate our commitment
to Jewish Canadians yeah yeah let's not
focus let's not focus on your mistakes
come breath all right yeah yeah
also to Ukrainian Canadians wow sounds
like something somebody that would tweet
out Hong Kong would say huh
seriously people who are fighting for
freedom I am really sick of these
[__] Nazis in Canada dude I'm
supposed to [__] giving them standing
ovations dude this is disgusting
honestly this is disgusting